I remember watching nightmare in Elm
Street and your performance so subtle
and real and not trying and they just
seem like a real person and when I
watched you in Nightmare it just was you
brought this grounded if it weren't for
you as the lead I mean Wes really
knocked it out of the park because it
was like if you would have got some
known actress or it could have been
completely but the fact that this is
innocent girl next door kind of
but real like an actor like I really
felt like you weren't trying you were
just being but he just had this way of
getting the lingo and the way that kids
talk to each other it wasn't perfect
because there were some lines I remember
we rolled our eyes like oh come on Wes
kids don't talk this way but in general
you know I was as close to Nancy as I
possibly could have been you know and
and and I have a feeling Wes saw that in
me and he he's like well let's just
match this girl who seems to be just
like Nancy and